大家好
这里是零度体说
最近有很多人私信我
要我说下如何在电脑上
本地部署Z-Image
这款无内容审查
支持NSFW输出的文身图模型
Z-Image它是一款功能强大
且高效的图像生成模型
拥有60亿仓数
能够生成高度逼真的作业级图像
同时可以保持优异的美学品质
关键是对中文理解非常精准
目前Z-Image有三个变种
分别是Z-Image Tonable
Z-Image Base
还有Z-Image Edit
根据基于i6的人类偏好评估
我们可以看到
Z-Image Torable
和其他领先的模型相比
拥有极强的竞争力
同时在开源的纹身图模型中
取得非常不错的结果
关键是它对显卡要求并不高
可以适配绝大部分
普通级的消费级电脑
比如8G显存引人跑
但如果想显存更快的话
那么12G以上的显存
将会是非常不错的选择
接下来我们先来详细说一下
如何在我们的电脑上
安装并预计这款
最近非常火热的
AI维生图模型
同时来测试下
它究竟能不能生存那种
需要达马上课
才能放出的图片
首先第一步
我们需要打开
零路博上这篇文章
上面也有我们
今天所需的全部资料
这个链接
我会放在视频下方
首先第一步
我们需要安装必备的环境
如果电脑上
没有安装Python环境的话
那么先打开它
官方推荐是Python 3.10
或3.11
那下面第一前往
好 打开以后
那就往下拉
在第一步我们找到这个下的链接
上方有这个Windows版本
还是Mac版本
到时根据自己情况选择就可以了
比如说选择Windows版本
64位的
打开它
总共是按赞左右
下载滑以后
我们打开机安装一下
打开以后这里要注意了
一定过去向方第二个选项
给它PASS在系统录音下
过去以后我们的上方有一个install now
把这个PASS 3.1连环境
给它安装到我们的地脑上
打开滑以后
它向方有个提示
问我们是否要禁止这个长度限制
这里面打开它
就取消它的限制
安装好的Person环境以后
那么点击关闭掉
接下来安装下第二个BP的环境
就Gate
那么点前往
打开它
打开以后面看到
它目前最新版本是这个I.5S的版本
这是它目前最新版本
那么下面有个Install for Windows
来进行安装一下
进入以后在上方这里我们选这64位的
就这个了
但如果是Arm结构的话
我们选第二个
对于绝大部分的电脑的话
我们选第一个就可以了
就把这64位给它动下来总共是60大左右下载好以后先打开它把Git安你安装一下点下一步然后后面我们可以保持默认就可以了点下一步点安装
点下一步
安装就可以了
如果你没有特殊需求的话
那么跟我们一样就行了
保持默认
直接点下一步安装就可以了
好 弄好以后
我们把Git去掉
点击Finish
那现在我需要重新回到刚才提示下
来下载并安装最新版本的
Confi UI客户端
那么在下方下载
打开它
打开以后
那先我给它动下来
那里上边有个下载Compify以外
进入以后面看到
它里面有两个版本
分别是Windows版本
还是Mac版本
这两个不同版本的话
它是有对应的要求的
比如说Windows版本
它是需要N卡的
如果你没有N卡的话
那么它的生存速度会大打折扣
但如果是Mac电脑的话
它是需要M系列芯片的
如果是之前老板的Mac的话
比如说英特拉芯片
那么它也是不支持的
所以这里要注意了
那先我给它动下来
因为电脑是Windows系统
所以这我选第一个就可以了
打开它 把它冻下来
总共是100多兆
那么点下载
好 下载好以后
然后先我们打开机安装一下
打开以后
它默认是安装在C盘的
但如果想把它放在其他盘域的话
那也是可以的
到时候可以点击浏览
到时候可以把它放在其他盘域上
比如说电脑经常重装系统的话
那么建议不要把它放在其他盘域上
选择好以后 接下来点击安装
安装好以后 点击完成
它就正式启动这个Convi 以外客户图了
在上方这里看到
它是可以切换不同语言的
比它目前支持英文
中文简体
反正中文都可以
到这根治情况选择就可以了
选择后就点击Get start
启动一下
这个它会让我们选择硬件
比如当天电脑是英文打显卡的话
那么选第一个就可以了
它效果是最好的
就可以通过这个N卡的库大引擎
加速AI图片生成
但如果你没有N卡的话
那么只能选第二个
就通过CPU进解码
所以的话就比较慢了
或者的话只能通过手中设置了
因为当天我选N卡
所以就会选第一个
那么点下一个
第二步的话它那么选择configure的安装位置
它默认是放在C盘那
当然你可以自定义
可以放在其他盘复也是可以的
第二选项的话是从现有安装迁移
如果你之前已经安装过configure的话
那么可以选第二选项
可以复制和链接之前现有的模型文件
第三选项的话就是手动选择下载服务器
它默认是通过gethub进行下载的
所以如果你不在海外的话
那么也得通过VPN机解决
否则的话它是没法进行下载的
如果需要VPN的用户
那么可以先返回到干扰铁子下
底下方有个VPN下载
到时候下载安装好以后
那么底下方有一个设置进入以后在下方这里看到一个高级设置展开它展开以后在下方里面看到它下面有一个通论模式就可以开启全球上网就可以了开启好以后我们重新连接下
这样的话就可以在
Combio上下载安装包了
那先返回去
那么点下一个
这一步它让我们配置
Combio在桌面上的行为
就第一个就是自动更新
它可以帮我们自动更新
最新的可用来安装包
那第二选项的话
就是数据收集
如果在意的话
你可以把它关闭掉
那这一步点安装
这样它开始设置Python环境
并安装ConfigUI
这一步的话
它会正式开始安装ConfigUI必备的环境包了
它目前正在安装PyTouch
这个过程可能需要一点时间
因为这个安装包是非常大的
在上方这里我们可以看到它的安装进度
因为PyTouch总共有三句多
当安装完成以后
它先开始启动ConfigUI了
正在启动ConfigUI服务器
如果你之前安装过ConfigUI的客户
那么它会自动更新到最新版本
它现在已经安装完成了
当你第一次进入以后
它是这样的
我们先关闭掉
然后现在需要返回到刚才铁的下
来获取工作流
打开以后
往下拉
在下方这里
第三步骤就获取工作流
我们上方有个深图工作流
进入以后
往下拉
在下方这里可以看到
它有一个Z-ImageTourable
文本主要图像工作流
我们上方就下载
打开它
打开以后
我们先把鼠标右键
点击认存为
给它放到桌面上
这样的话
我们就获取工作流了
现在重新回到
CombieEU口
然后先把我们刚才获取的工作流
给它扔进来
分录好以后
这样的话它上方会提示
当前我们介绍必备的模型
然后现在第三方有一个下载
把这模型文件给它倒入下来
总共四个
全部给它下载下来
这下过程的话
给它需要一点时间
因为它目前总共有十几个G
当模型下载完成以后
它就把它关闭掉
那今天我们来试一下
看行不行
这是它目前这个展示工作流
在上方这里看一下
这里我们可以修改一下
它分辨率
在下方这里
它默认是10S乘以10S的
但是如果你需要的话
你可以把这个分辨率性修改一下
比如生成1280 x 720的
去看好以后
在上方这里贴入我们需要的提示词
上方这个提示词的话
你可以自由发挥
你想生成什么图片的话
那你就输入对应的提示词就可以了
它是没有任何内容限制的
那先把准备找提示词来试一下
比如他帮我生成一个
写实的写真风格的图片
我把这个提示词给Copy出来
底下方有个Copy按钮
把复杂好以后
那么贴进来给它添入到这里添入好用的DDP形象来看一下它生效果怎么样因为当前我的这个显存是24GB的
所以它生的速度是非常快的
只需要几秒就可以搞定
来看一下它立马就完成了
当然如果我们就是不满意的话
那么在下方这里它有个总值设置
你可以随便自己一下
就可以更改
更改完整以后来重新运行一下
它就可以帮我们生成一张新的图片
就我们试一下这个甜美日系风感
来试一下
重新提论一下
我们先把分辨率去修改一下
稍微改大一点吧
改成1920x1080的
修改后给你运行一下
重新生成一下图片
这个速度确实非常快
硬板就可以搞定
那现在换个种子来试一下
重新生成一张新的
当然我们可以在后面增加其他元素
比如戴上墨镜
衣服改成红色的
然后重新生成就可以了
速度非常快
这个速度非常快
同时我们可以输入简单的提示纸
今天帮我给这个登科后进行配图
最出名的两句
这样的话他立马也搞定了
对珠萌理解非常精准
大家可以在这里好多人会好奇啊
他来不帮我们生成那种特殊的图片
这个提示纸的话大家可以自己去想就行了
大家看一下确实是可以的
只不过这图片必须打码才可以了
不能放出来了
同时在左侧有个模板这里我们可以选择更多的模型
大家可以看到
他里面又有一个Z-ImageTolable维生图模型
大家看一下
他也会这种帮我们安装好的
它跟我们刚才下载好的模型是一样的
到时候在里面输入提示词就可以了
当然如果电脑硬件不达标的话
那么可以通过这个Z-Image Turbo
它有一个免费在线平台来使用也是可以的
到时候回到刚才铁的下
第三位前往
打开Z-Image Turbo免费在线平台
打开以后
拿到左上方这里贴入我们提示词就可以了
应该最后发挥提示词了
就点击生存
它是完全免费的
利用是共享GPU
速度还是非常快的
但是网络风的话可能会慢一点
因为它可能需要排队
白天画速度非常快
大家看一下
几乎两秒钟就可以搞定一张图片
它的深度质量也非常高
而且它深度的内容也没有任何限制
你想成什么图片的话
只要输入对应提示就可以了
更多其他玩法的话
大概只要尝试
好 今天视频所运的全部资料
他们还下载链接
我都放在视频下方您的薄薯
by bwd6